Hello, welcome to another members' minute. This is Michelle Hamburger, and I am here with Dr. Connors.
And today we're going to talk about a new thing that we started and these are making poltis sachets
for people to use as poltis's over-cancer
spots in their body, whether it's a breast cancer,
could be even over open wood, could be over the liver, could be over the prostate area,
that's the idea of a poltis.
Well, in an effort to try to pursue every single avenue that we can for helping our patients,
we are wanting to try to provide more and more
topical options for people to suit their skin. There are a lot of patients that we have
that are dealing with cancers that are either a skin cancer itself, or are pushing up through
the skin, or are manifesting in different irritating skin conditions. And so we have been doing
some research and came to the conclusion that instead of doing things to try to specifically draw
cancer out of a person's body, which can be very painful, what are things that we can do to
infuse that skin, in a sense, or saturate it with a medicinal product. And sachets are a fantastic
remedy. It's been used for centuries, and it's something that we wanted to start to incorporate
into our own practice. Yeah, herbal poltis go way back. It's kind of been lost in modern medicine,
with the advent of medications. And to bring that back and to use these old therapies can be
extremely beneficial. So what we did is we thought, well, let's just create this and it'll get
our patients thinking too to maybe add things to it and play with the different poltis
creations and herbal concoctions that they're going to put together that what might be best for them.
So what we did is we have some organic, organically sourced herbals that we started with as a base.
And then we added some herbal flower essences. We started with just two lavender and collendula.
And those would be nice soothing essences to go along with the cancer-chillian herbs.
And we put them in a sachet bag like this. And we source this. These are just organic cotton
sourced sachet bags. And we mixed those ingredients up in a container and then we give people a
baggie of those ingredients. And then they put a few tablespoons into the sachet bag and then
heat that up, put it in hot water, and put that on their liver or on their breast or on their
wound or on their and and use it as a nice heat source. It's herbal draw. It's herbal infusion.
It can be really healing. We'll include with it what this nice little direction sheet, right?
So on this direction sheet, we just brainstormed on how to use it. So this talks about what I
just said about using it. But then some different therapeutic options to add to it. You can use
the zig spray. Oh, you can use other essential oils or like Emu or CBD oil. I also added in or
we added in the macravage active any factor oil. If that's something that you're also taking,
you can also add to it or wet the actual sachet. If you have some liquid supplements that you are
taking, you can water down or dilute that liquid supplement and then use that as the activating liquid
in your sachet. And that can create an extra boost of nutraceutical benefit. So we want to hear back
from you on how you're using them and how they benefited you. If you think that they're working,
what options you've tried that have been most beneficial because it's really going to be that
individual practice of everybody and feeding back to us how they're working to see the success
that you're having. The big thing that we want to just worry about is with the directions,
you put it in a hot water, we still want you to burn yourself. So make sure you check the temperature
of it before you put it on your skin and have fun with it. Yep, definitely. One last thing to consider
is that if you happen to be somebody with an open wound that may change the way that you can use
the sachet. So especially if that wound happens to be weeping, you may find that you can use the
sachet better or for longer if you place it around the wound. Not to say that you can't place it
in the wound, but you may have to take some extra measures to clean the sachet itself in between
administrations. Just to make sure that that sachet doesn't become something that is gross to your
and to your liking. Yeah, we want to cause a spread of infection or something like that. So be
wise with the use, enjoy and let us know how it goes. Looking forward to it.